this could be the shape of Iraq's new
leadership president Fuad Masum has
appointed Shiite politician haider
al-abadi to form a new government within
30 days it's the ultimate snug for
two-time Prime Minister Nouri al-maliki
he and core supporters are insisting
that he should keep the top job on
Monday hundreds of demonstrators took to
the streets of the capital to show their
support for the incumbent premier is a
gym Orion we demand that President Ford
masoom support Maliki he leads the
biggest parliamentary bloc the head of
the Shiite National Coalition must also
support Maliki this is a mass demand and
a constitutional one haha matlab llaman
haiti with the story opponents say
Maliki has failed to pull together a
deeply fractured country autonomous
Kurds in the north say they have little
voice in the central government and
minority Sunnis complained they've been
largely excluded by the ruling Shiites
in Baghdad it is Sunni disaffection that
is said to be feeding support for the
jihadist Islamic state the US and EU
believed that only a government of
national unity will be capable of
halting the militant advance and because
Maliki has largely ignored pleas for
national unity he's been asked to step
aside but he remains defiant and he's
even threatened to sue President masoom
seen here on the left men a jalaja Sabah
is violated the constitution to favor
the interests of his own groups over
those of the Iraqi people Maliki
deployed special forces loyal to him at
major intersections in Baghdad further
underscoring the degree of political
instability